alors je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
nouvelle rubrique avec vous Véronique
Iturbide vous viendrez désormais ici
tous les mardis pour nous donner
quelques nouvelles insolites du
département des Yvelines cette semaine
ce sont les animaux qui ont attiré votre
attention alors cette chronique on l'a
appelé les insolites de Véronique à
propos des animaux on va commencer par
parler des sapins de Noël invendus et
qui sont réutilisés de manière à
s'originale exactement alors en lisant
Le Parisien j'ai trouvé la réponse à une
question que je ne me posais pas mais je
vous en fais part tout de même à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on offre aux animaux du zoo
Thoiry à Noël parce que il y a pas de
raison d'accord et deuxième question
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des sapins vendus
vous imaginez ce gâchiez de sapin déjà
coupé
bien sûr alors en fait c'est sapins sont
donnés aux animaux du zoo Thoiry ce que
l'on méritait bien sûr alors les hyènes
les gorilles les Panthères les tigres
chacun y a droit qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
font alors soit en fait déjà l'idée
c'est que ce sont des épicéas donc les
sapins qui sont que le plus forts donc
ça leur donne une bonne nouvelle odeurs
là qui qui leur fait vraiment plaisir à
la truffe et il joue avec qui prennent
ça pour une proie ils se frotte le dos
enfin plein de trucs et puis après ben
comme comme ce qui arrive souvent tout
passe qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces sapins
kingdominus plus personne on les broie
et il servent de compost organique qu'on
met dans les jardins du parc du zoo de
Thoiry
on va continuer avec une association qui
s'occupe de de sauver des fonds aussi de
manière originale oui voilà alors j'ai
prononcé le mot broyé je vais le
prononcer malheureusement alors en fait
c'est une arboricultrice de Feucherolles
qui produit des kiwis qui est donc
Feucherolles donc la plaine de
Versailles et qui a réalisé que si elle
coupait les hautes herbes de sa prairie
elle risquait très très probablement de
de broyer excusez-moi mais c'est le mot
des défends soit chevreuil c'est plutôt
chevreuil il avait 9 Versailles où ça
peut être aussi des des fonds de biche
mais peu importe alors il faut savoir
que le fond de chevreuil il fait 2 kg à
peine et le fond de biche il fait un peu
plus cinq six bon bref alors pourquoi
est-ce que donc c'est juste horrible et
surtout qu'après une fois déchiqueté
c'est peu bête elles sont intégrées dans
les mottes de onemote dont les meules
enfin bref dans les bottes
dans les bottes de foin et bah ça
pourrit ça ça fabrique des toxines qui
qui donnent le botulisme imaginez-vous
au pauvage qui vont manger ce foin
c'était vraiment deux deux choses
vraiment pas super alors du coup
pourquoi les biches viennent mettre leur
bébé dans ses hautes herbes parce
qu'elle les croit à l'abri savoir que
dans la forêt les sangliers sont pas ne
crachent pas sur un petit rôti de fond
donc ils se font croquer dans les forêts
donc elles les mettent là de sachant pas
bien évidemment que la fenaison a lieu
en mai avant c'était en août donc les
fans ils étaient déjà partis là c'est en
mai réchauffement climatique oblig donc
elle s'imagine qu'ils sont bien cachés
et voilà alors que faire donc cette
fameuse
Leslie elle fait elle veut agir elle
s'est renseignée en France elle a pas
trouvé beaucoup de renseignements donc
elle s'est tournée vers l'Allemagne et
la Suisse il y a une association suisse
qui lui a conseillé de d'acquérir un
drone thermique alors un drone thermique
ça coûte très cher mais l'avantage c'est
que il détermine en fait le point de
chaleur c'est là où sera donc le bébé
par rapport au froid de la prairie voilà
et donc il faut un drone thermique il
faut un pilote il faut lui payer alors
on achète le drone après il faut payer
la formation spécifique du pilote et
après il faut des bénévoles parce que
cette cette recherche de fond en mai se
fait entre 5 et 7 le matin parce que
c'est là où il le contrat c'est plus
important entre le froid de la prairie
et le chaud du bébé donc voilà après
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on y touche pas
parce que l'odeur humaine ça plaira pas
la mer donc on met une cage et comme ça
le l'engin agricole repère la bête et
après qu'est-ce qui se passe et bah il
faut être nombreux donc pour se lever de
5 heures il faut aussi que les
promeneurs de chiens tiennent si
possible en laisse leur bête au mois de
mai parce que ça peut faire beaucoup de
dégâts aussi alors les kiwis de Leslie
c'est la page Facebook et l'association
des la plaine de Versailles si vous
voulez participer bénévolement
financièrement enfin être bénévole ou
faire un don
on va quitter les animaux et on va
passer aux gourmand et au gourmets il y
en a peut-être autour de la table avec
une nouvelle adresse qui s'ouvre à
Versailles exactement qui s'est ouverte
alors ça s'appelle ça c'est ouvert les
quelques temps sont deux deux jeunes
hommes qui l'ont ouvertes un chef et un
entrepreneur Jérémy et Renaud pardon ça
s'appelle la rotissy alors la rôtissaï
c'est sous les halles du marché du
Notre-Dame à Versailles et on a des
images on a quelques images du site
internet et donc donc la rôtissaï donc
c'est vraiment à l'intérieur du de la
halte qui s'appelle le carré à la marée
vous savez il y a quatre carrés donc
carré à la marée donc dès 10h30 vous
pouvez aller vous restaurer le principe
c'est qu'il propose une quinzaine de
viande différente qui sont donc rôties
voilà vous choisissez votre viande c'est
qualité françaises enfin super qualité
géante vous choisissez votre garniture
votre sauce machin et voilà etc vous
pouvez aussi donc entre 10h30 et 18h30
vous restaurez vous êtes un peu au
milieu des gens il y a un bar avec des
tabourets ou alors des manches debout si
vous avez envie de compléter votre repas
par du fromage ou un dessert vous allez
juste la boutique juste à côté acheter
votre fromage et votre gâteau aux faces
et vous la portez là voilà c'est c'est
fait pour quoi c'est la liberté chacun
fait ce qu'il veut et après c'est aussi
un traiteur il fume leur saumon vous
pouvez leur commander n'importe quoi ils
savent faire
voilà je crois que j'ai tout dit et puis
bon on était on était là au beau jour il
y aura encore d'autres projets mais on
en reparlera ce qui est une information
qui a retenu votre attention j'ai fait
y aller pour déguster je pense pas il y
a aussi des burgers pardon originaux qui
changeront de des steaks vous avez
burgers
de la soupe alors vous avez des burgers
c'est 8h30
de canard de poulet enfin ça change pour
tous les sur
un concert qui vous tient à cœur et pour
lequel il faut se dépêcher si on veut
avoir sa place exactement alors ça me
tient à cœur parce qu'en fait c'est Tim
dope qui est un jeune chanteur d'origine
de il est d'origine Rambouillet oui il
est du sudible
c'est un jeune rambolitain il est né 94
il a commencé sa carrière de musiciens
en 2015 son premier album est sorti en
2017 il est auteur compositeur
producteur on fait tout et bien en plus
il sort son 4e album Les Immortels début
février et il démarre en fait un premier
concert à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse le
vendredi 20 janvier à 20h30 alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut y aller parce
que Tim dope il est il est doué
talentueux et il est généreux donc là il
va jouer gratuitement pour l'association
le reste Fugain l'association l'aurait
de Fugain c'est une association qui aide
à lutter contre la leucémie et autres
cancer du sang pour aussi inciter les
dons de plaquettes etc voilà et donc le
la mérite de Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
prête évidemment gratuitement la salle
de l'Espace Jean Racine le Lion's Club
de la Vallée de Chevreuse s'occupe du
staff de la billetterie etc et team de
peu jouent gratuitement et l'intégralité
des recettes c'est 25 euros le billet
ira directement à l'association Laurette
Fugain donc c'est vendredi 20 janvier il
reste des places pas 50 000 mais il en
reste et franchement ça vaut le coup à
découvrir pour pour toutes les
informations merci merci Véronique pour
cette première chronique on vous
retrouve aussi la présentation des Vy P
sur TV bientôt